that's the one okay so click on that but
don't play the audio click on that I
want the audience to see this okay so
she is they're doing what they're doing
turn off the audio and just press play
what the lady is saying right now she's
saying breaking news okay press pause
okay so press pause okay so this is the
first time
on CNN an anti-trump Camp is talking
about
Trump's entire family is getting sued in
New York okay on a 14 million subscriber
Channel
zoom in how many views this thing got
zoom in how many views this thing got so
they can see it this should be 17
million views 10 million views you know
what the American people are saying oh
we don't give a [ __ ] yeah we're over it
then but all I'm saying to you if it was
like when Russia happened and what was
the guy's name on Russia I know we have
information on the what was the guy's
names uh Adam uh Adams ship Adam ship
right Peter schiff's last time Adam
Schiff so when he got up you know how
many views it got nearly 10 million
views 8 million views
the American people simply are sitting
there saying listen man get over it move
on we understand you hate this guy we
got it yeah you hate this guy okay and
and we're fine whether he wins or
doesn't you know totally get it but this
is a little bit too much would you have
guest Tyler Adam would you have guests
for something like this to get 341 000
views breaking news well I I just think
it it speaks to The credibility of CNN
and what people are watching on there
for instance a clip came up on my
YouTube just a little perspective this
is a million uh subscriber Channel
you're familiar with this guy Brian
Tyler Cohen he speaks out against Trump
he's proudly a Democrat he's got a
million views same same story and a
million subscribers that's what I'm
saying is that people are looking for
other outlets that maybe are less biased
or have more credibility you would think
like this is a home run for CNN breaking
news this is what's about to happen and
the American people are saying let them
just compete if he doesn't when he
doesn't how would you compare that to
the to the two or three videos right
before that or after that is it all
something I watched all of them so zoom
out zoom out so he can see this not even
this story I'm saying in general okay
zoom out
go back to the channel yeah just go back
to the channel so zoom in a little bit
so we can see all the views zoom in zoom
in zoom in zoom in okay so 51 000 it's
voter stun uh zoom in okay so Putin
people are interested in Putin more than
they're interested in New York you gotta
be kidding me
Trump's poll numbers are making things
they're more interested in his poll
numbers than their interest so that's
higher Biden responds to Putin okay
they're interested in that so sweep in
condemnation heroin and react okay uh uh
580 now what's the next one a retired
kernel on potential impact of 300 000 uh
more Russians exactly but but Michael
Cohen 599 okay nothing is in the
millions the voters are telling you CNN
move on and let's see who's going to get
elected what are your thoughts on this
just looking at the Optics and a number
Steward yeah no I listen I agree I
thought it was a non-factor in fact you
know generally speaking uh the Attorney
General of New York would have initiated
a civil investigation meaning they would
have gotten a complaint through the
channels and they would have
investigated it and then if they would
have realized that there may have been
criminal conduct they referred to either
the feds or to the county of which who
would have jurisdiction in this case in
what is left out is that New York County
and also the southern district of New
York I don't already investigated this
and had already come to the conclusion
that it was a non-issue that there were
no criminal violations so now this woman
who all of a sudden has some you know
the Holy Grail is trying to suggest now
not only we can commence civil
litigation civil litigation but we have
the Smoking Gun to suggest that we have
now evidence of some crime that has been
committed it's hogwash it's it's
nonsense and as I told you off camera I
said I bought a lot of popcorn popcorn
I'm going to sit on my couch I'm gonna
eat the popcorn and watch this Sideshow
because it's ridiculous
uh I think that um as I watch the news
and uh obviously
in the Hispanic Community
um everybody what you see it in
Telemundo right and um this is making
news too and I think that uh the more I
talk to a Hispanic community
uh like going back to what you were
pointing about 341 000 views they have
no idea Pat that they are pushing so
many people to become Trump fans well
when you push somebody so much you get
to wonder why do you hate them so much
that's what ends up happening like kind
of what happened with Andrew Tate a lot
of people didn't know who Andrew Tate
was up until you canceled him now
everybody's looking him up right and I
think that's what's happening right now
that they're just uh
um people are waking up and like
wondering like man this guy scares you
if you're doing that much you're sending
the FBI to his house and you're doing
everything every time you turn on the
news Spanish too there's Jorge Ramos
there's Paola Ramos which is his
daughter which was part of uh a lot of
people don't know Hillary Clinton's
um uh when she was running for president
Jorge Ramos's daughter was part of that
camp and she was going to have a
position in the white house so a lot of
people didn't know that so he was
politically motivated to go against
Trump but you try to use everything he's
Trump like bro he's been out of office
for two years but the more they do this
and they do things like this it starts
to push people towards them as opposed
against them and this is again this is
backfiring and it's backfiring nasty
especially in our community they just
did a poll that 55 percent of Hispanics
are now flipping to become uh to voting
for Trump in 2024 if he decides to run
if he's going to run if whatever he five
percent fifty five percent well he was
at a he was he's at a 55 approval rating
he was only at a 20 25 in 2016. yeah
interesting is that Trump or the
Republican party no Trump specifically
bro Mexicans don't know nothing about
the Republican party they only they only
Associated Republican party with Trump
that's it so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]